[Musik]
für die triste verwende ich ein päckchen
backpulver teig 50 gramm butter und für
die nuss mischung brauche ich jeweils 50
gramm wahllose haselnüsse mandeln
pistazien 50 gramm braunem zucker und
etwas zimt schön den rammstein form
bestreichen damit die lüfterblätter
gleich daran haften jetzt nehmt ihr die
teig blätter und die sind wirklich ganz
ganz ganz dünn
ihr könnt sie auch gerne auseinander
reisen immer mal wieder butter
einstreichen und so vor mich jetzt die
torten kruste der boden bildet so
erstmal vorgebacken und ich kann ihnen
der zwischenzeit die ausbildung
vorbereiten
die nüsse werde ich jetzt grob hacken
sie hier auf den herd und werden bei
mittel hoher hitze gerüstet jetzt kommt
hier etwas zimt dazu und der brauner
zucker dann ziehe ich die
karamellisierte müsse vom herd herunter
das lasse ich jetzt ganz kurz abkühlen
und kann schon mal die chiefs gegen
wasser zubereiten für die kiesfüllung
verwende ich 500 gramm frischkäse im
doppel ram stufe 100 gramm sahne joghurt
40 gramm stärke 40 gramm honig 100 gramm
zucker etwas vanille extrakt vier eier
und den saft und die schale einer
zitrone zuerst nämlich jetzt den
frischkäse den ferro ich ganz kurz damit
der küchen frei wird der joghurt bringt
so eine leichte säure eine schöne
frische mit rein kurz berührt jetzt gebe
ich hier einfach noch die restlichen
zutaten mit rein also etwas vanille
extrakt stärke etwas honig dann zucker
er ist nämlich nur ein kleines bisschen
zitronen abrieb ganz kleine krise
wirklich und jetzt einfach noch ein
bisschen zitronensaft dazu jetzt schön
langsam rühren
es gebe ich die nüsse erstmal auf den
teigboden da kommt jetzt die cheesecake
masse vorsichtig darüber jetzt ganz
vorsichtig bis zum rand streichen und
dann bei 130 grad in den backofen so
dass die masse schön langsam stoppt
jetzt kommt hier noch die sandschicht
drauf für die creme nämlich 200 gramm
sahne 130 gramm puderzucker etwas
vanille extrakt und seiner partei das
nehme ich zuerst entspannt
der kommt hier in die schüssel und wird
jetzt gemeinsam mit der sahne verrührt
vanille extrakt noch ein puderzucker und
ein bisschen verrühren und dann mit
seiner partei schlagen creme gebe ich
jetzt hier oben drauf ich bin ihr könnt
den cheesecake auch so lassen aber ich
finde eine weiße creme als abschluss
echt schön jetzt ganz vorsichtig
glattstreichen jetzt nehme ich hier noch
die nüsse die zurückgelegt habe und die
sträucher jetzt hier noch an den rand
und dann kommt die torte nochmal in den
kühlschrank wird war ein bis zwei
stunden bis sie richtig schön durch
kühlt und dann probieren wir der kuren
ersetzt schön kalt
jetzt sehe ich ihn samt der bug folie
direkt auf meiner platte
[Musik]
für den zuckersirup wendig 300
milliliter wasser 300 gramm zucker da
nehme ich jetzt um cocos blüten zucker
eine standard zimt 200 gramm honig und
ein spritzer zitronensaft
es gebe jetzt hier den choristen zucker
in einem topf sind stange auf wasser
dazu und obwohl ich jetzt einfach so
lange einkochen lassen bis der see rot
wenn man ihnen herunter tropfen lässt
wie ein faden läuft jetzt ist der sirup
soweit ich habe jetzt ein held bereits
ausgestellt jetzt lasse ich ihn wirklich
komplett abkühlen nehme nach etwa fünf
minuten
die zinsspanne raus ansonsten wird das
aroma zu intensiv hier gebe ich jetzt
auf den spritzer zitronensaft dazu und
dann lasse ich jetzt den sirup komplett
abkühlen
für die füllung verwende ich 250 gramm
haselnüsse 30 gramm kakaopulver
ungesüßte einen teelöffel zimt etwas
tonkabohne eine prise salz 50 gramm
kaunitz zum bestreichen brauche ich
mutter und natürlich die baklava bled
haben ich nehme mir zuerst die butter
die habe ich extra in seinem iphone
die darf nämlich auch auf den herd dann
kurz schmelzen lassen dann die nuss
führung dafür gebe ich jetzt schon mal
dem zimt in eine große schüssel dann
etwas salz dazu und tonkabohne davon
immer nur ganz wenig nehmen weiter
muskatnuss da kommt hier das kakaopulver
mit reinen und nehme zusätzlich noch
cacau nebst und das gibt dem ganzen noch
einen schönen krank hier kommen jetzt
noch dem nutzer mit dazu
die werde ich jetzt vorher selber malen
[Musik]
ich habe jetzt hier meine glas
auflaufform ihr solltet jetzt auf jeden
fall ne form nehmen die dicht ist und
tedi baklava blätter ist durch die form
hier drauf ich glaube so passt es ganz
gut beschreibt das jetzt hierzu jetzt
die form mit der butter bestreichen sie
kommt jetzt die erste schicht rein dann
nehme ich gleich schon zwei drei blätter
dann kommt zwischen reihen immer mal
wieder ein bisschen butter und ich lege
jetzt etwa die hälfte der blätter rein
und zwischen rhein auch den verschnitt
kommentiert die nuss füllung rein
jetzt kommen hier einfach noch die
übrigen teigschichten drauf auch mit der
butter dazwischen schön alles abdecken
jetzt einfach die restliche butter
einmal komplett auf die oberfläche geben
und dann wird es jetzt gleich
geschnitten bevor es gebacken wird nach
dem backen ist es nämlich zu knusprig
und ich schneide jetzt gleich in
dreiecke also erstmal rechtecke
schneiden und dem dreieck beim schneiden
einfach immer nur darauf achten nicht
segen und auch kein sehr games oder ein
schönes glattes und wirklich nur noch
unten schneiden also einmal durch hacken
sozusagen das habe ich hier noch ein
bisschen rest mutter die kommt hier noch
obendrauf
und dann kommt in den backofen und daf
richtig knusprig gebacken werden aber
wie gesagt ich muss sicher stellen dass
der zucker sirup schon richtig gut
abgekühlt ist
jetzt ist das backpulver gebacken und
jetzt den abgekühlten sirup ganz
vorsichtig darüber fließen lassen
wenn ihr möchtet dann könnt ihr das bak
war vor dem servieren noch mit
schokolade übergießen
dafür habe ich einfach 50 gramm peter
kuvertüre gehackt zwei drittel davon
über dem warmen wasserbad erwärmt und
dann kommt da ein halber teelöffel
kokosfett dazu ihr könnt dann vom herd
herunternehmen dann das restliche
drittel einrühren und schon ist die
kuvertüre temperiert
[Musik]
für meinen helm brauche ich 200 gramm
butter 450 gramm mehl 200 gramm
puderzucker 300 gramm sesampaste also
dahin vanille extrakt und pistazien
deshalb wird jetzt ganz traditionell im
topf zubereitet dafür nehme ich jetzt
die butter und kann sie erst einmal
vorsichtig schmelzen lassen jetzt kann
ich hier vorsichtig das mehl einrühren
und daraus wird so eine art mehlschwitze
gemacht und jetzt wird diese
mehlschwitze solange angebraten bis sie
so leicht bräunlich wird und bis auch
der milde geschmack verschwindet jetzt
kommt der puderzucker dazu und wird auch
noch kurz ein gerührt ich würde kann ich
die masse vom herd herr unternehmen die
jetzt kommt nämlich dass dahin rein also
die sesampaste und jetzt so lange rühren
bis die knöpfchen verschwunden sind und
wer möchte kann einen teil davon mit
paco verrühren für ne kako variante
dafür nehme ich jetzt einfach etwas
kakao und verrührt es mit dem tal hin
und färbt an etwa ein drittel davon
damit ein
bei mir kommen jetzt die pistazien noch
rein wir auch welche jetzt kommt die
masse in eine form rein und wird dann
gepresst damit sie später schön raus
gestürzt werden kann ihr könnt jetzt zum
beispiel auch so ein glas verwenden
einfach nur vorm eurer wahl
ich verwende jetzt in der kastenform und
habe die mit frischhaltefolie
ausgekleidet damit ich das später wieder
rausbekommen
und jetzt kommt ein bisschen von der
hellen masse ryan dunn von der dunklen
masse und da kann ich das ein bisschen
vermischen und jetzt lasse ich so
abgedeckt bei zimmertemperatur abkühlen
und dann kommt noch mal für zwei stunden
in den kühlschrank
[Musik]
ich mache heute ein zusammenspiel aus
cannoli und dem türkischen kinder für
kinder ist es jetzt aber nicht diese
teig fäden die heißen kraft ich bereite
jetzt hier erstmal das engelshaar vor
und zwar zum tier das ganz vorsichtig
auseinander
ich ziehe jetzt hier die teig strenge
ganz vorsichtig auseinander
ich nehme jetzt hier eine höhere nicht
in form jetzt nehmt ihr einfach die
butter bestreicht die form damit jetzt
einen langen tag streife nehmen den
ersten hier unten so ein bisschen
befestigen und dann von oben nach unten
schön dicht auf rollen dann gerne
einfach den nächsten nehmen noch mal
dran setzen und so dicht wie möglich auf
rollen anschließend dann mit der butter
bestreichen die gibt dem ganzen noch mal
ein bisschen form und natürlich auch
geschmack jetzt hier nochmal schön mit
butter bestreichen und sobald sich die
teilten die folge sagt haben mit der
butter lassen sie sich auch besser
formen also dann drücke ich sie noch mal
an dem hörnchen schön fest ich war kurz
meine hände und steht dir schon mal in
den backofen so dass er wirklich schön
goldbraun geröstet werden und kann ihn
da zwischenzeit auch schon mal den
zuckersirup machen für den zuckersirup
verwende ich 150 gramm zucker 75 gramm
wasser einen spritzer zitronensaft und
ein teelöffel rosenwasser und gibt jetzt
einfach alle zutaten in der topf also
erst zucker und wasser lasse ich jetzt
aufkochen und den zuckersirup bereitet
man immer so zu dass der einfach schön
abkühlen kann
deswegen mache ich denn jetzt direkt
jetzt kocht der sirup da gebe ich jetzt
einem spritzer zitronensaft dazu und für
den geschmack ein bisschen rosenwasser
jetzt lasse ich ihn einfach nur 23
minuten köcheln bis er am faden
herunterläuft den sirup lasse ich jetzt
abkühlen und kann in der zwischenzeit
schon mal die zitronencreme zu bereiten
für die zitronencreme verwende ich 50
gramm zitronensaft 70 gramm zucker 250
gramm mascarpone etwas vanille extrakt
300 gramm sahne und salat
die mascarpone ihr könnt aber auch
frischkäse nehmen kurz verrühren
dann bruder zucker dazu dann langsam die
sahne dazugeben mit zitronensaft
verfeinern mangel extrakt nicht
vergessen und mit seiner fahrt steif
schlagen jetzt einfach die creme in
einen spritzbeutel füllen mit einer
stelle zum beispiel hier sitzen
spritzbeutel echt empfehlenswert denn
die hörnchen lassen sich ansonsten
wirklich sehr schwer erfüllen
jetzt nehme ich die abgekühlten hörnchen
ganz vorsichtig setzte schon mal auf
meinen servierteller dann vorsichtig das
hörnchen rausziehen jetzt mit hilfe des
spritzbeutel ganz vorsichtig die creme
ein film erst mal hinten ausstopfen und
dann ruhig nach vorne bisschen
verlängern
das nehme ich noch frische erdbeeren so
dann gehackten pistazien noch drüber und
wenn ihr möchtet noch gerne den sirup
drüber laufen lassen
ein bisschen davon
[Musik]
für den kuchenteig brauche ich feiere
eine prise salz etwas vanille extrakt
200 gramm zucker jeweils 200 milliliter
milch oder butter milch hier habe ich
noch 200 milliliter ein päckchen
backpulver 50 gramm kakaopulver und 250
gramm mehl
ich nehme jetzt zuerst einmal die eier
wie bei einem rolls und geht den eine
große schüssel
das ganze könnte jetzt mit dem
handrührgerät oder auch mit der
küchenmaschine zu bereiten
da kommt vanille extrakt mit rein eine
prise salz und zucker und die mischung
wird dann für etwa 45 minuten cremig
verrührt wenn die hamas hat und schön
cremig ist so wie ich hier kommen jetzt
die flüssigkeiten mit dazu als nächstes
kann ich jetzt die trockenen zutaten
dazu sieben also mail kakao und
backpulver und die werden jetzt auch
kurz eingerührt
den teig fühle ich jetzt in meiner
backform 1 die habe ich bereits gerettet
und auch gewählt damit der kuchen später
einfach wieder ganz leicht rauskommt und
so kommt datei gibt es in den
vorgeheizten backofen bei 170 grad ober
unterhitze für etwa 20 bis 25 minuten
beide kuchen teige dürfen nach dem
backen etwa zehn minuten abkühlen
zweiten raus stürzen damit jetzt der
kuchen aber nicht an dem tuch klebt
können jetzt zum beispiel zucker
drüberstreuen damit das ganze aber nicht
so süß wird nämlich einfach lecker
stärke und jetzt in kuchen raus stützen
und während der kuchen abkühlt kann ich
schon mal die füllung zubereiten und
fragt kommt da eine art pudding rhein
wird das morabit brauche ich 800
milliliter milch 50 gramm zucker 60 km
strecke das ist jetzt maisstärke einen
esslöffel reis stärke und etwas man im
extrakt jetzt nehme ich die milz und der
größte teil der mehr licht kommen wir zu
einem topf und einen teil der ich
berühre ich jetzt mit der stärke
das heißt ich habe jetzt hier den mais
stärke und stark kommt noch die reis
stärke dazu da kommt die restliche milch
mit rein und dann kann ich das schon mal
glatt rühren
es war mir nicht im topf gebe ich jetzt
noch den zucker mit rein und auch mandel
extrakt und da können jetzt auch gerne
ein bis zwei teelöffel nehmen
das ganze soll wirklich intensiv nach
manila schmecken und sobald die milch
kommt nehme ich sie auch sofort vom herd
herunter damit sie nicht überkauft ruhig
hier die stärke mischung ein
und dann kommt der topf gleich wieder
auf den herd drauf und ich lass dir
mischung dann nur noch kurz aufkochen
jetzt erkennt ihr vielleicht schon dass
die konsistenz auch ein bisschen anders
ist es wird auch super schnell fest
damit schneller abkühlt würde ich das
jetzt hier um und damit sich keine haut
auf der oberfläche bildet wenn ich das
ganze jetzt mit frischhaltefolie
abdecken und dann abkühlen lassen
beide kurven helfen sind jetzt abgekühlt
und der pudding dessen bisschen lauwarm
aber das ist auch völlig okay so nämlich
die folie weg und kann das ganze jetzt
mit dem schneebesen noch ein bisschen
glatt rühren die masse fühle ich jetzt
in einen spritzbeutel da habe ich eine
lokale vorne drin
und jetzt kann ich die vertiefungen
damit befüllen und jetzt kommt der
deckel dran und zwar nehme ich jetzt die
seite wo ich vorhin ein bisschen was
abgerissen habe nimmt es als unterseite
das heißt ich stürzt das jetzt auf einen
trockenen retter für das kann ich jetzt
mit hilfe des ortes hier drauf setzen
der kurs ist in den kühlschrank für etwa
eine stunde und nach dieser stunde werde
ich dem schokokuss zubereiten und dann
kann nämlich schon serviert werden
für den schokoladen christ brauche ich
insgesamt 200 milliliter flüssigkeit ich
habe jetzt hier zwei ist ressort das
sind 80 milliliter und den rest für dich
mit 100
wann sich mit allmählich auf 80 gramm
puderzucker 20 gramm kakaopulver und 100
gramm schokolade jetzt nämlich zuerst
einmal die beiden flüssigkeiten
sie kommen in den topf da kommt ihr
futter zucker mit dazu und kakao und
jetzt nächste mischung einmal
aufgebraucht werden und dann auf die
schokolade einrollen die sauce ist jetzt
gut verrührt die lasse ich jetzt
abkühlen und weil sie dann auch gleich
um film und dann kann ich sie kurz vor
dem servieren über die tortenstücke
gießen
[Musik]
[Applaus]